this program contains copyrighted
material that may be used for purposes
such as criticism comment news reporting
teaching scholarship or research under
the provisions of section 107 of the
Copyright Act of
1976 All rights to the copyrighted
material used in this program are
reserved to their respective
[Music]
owners
the battle between good and evil is a
Perpetual conflict it encompasses every
facet of The Human Experience in today's
episode we unveil a variety of methods
that the enemy uses to deceive Our Guest
Pastor John lomacang produced an
incredible series titled unclean spirits
that unmasks the occult and
entertainment industry he's here to give
us insights on that series welcome
Pastor LMA Kang thank you so much
blessing it's good to be here today so I
remember seeing the series and it's
really a great series but too long to
present today but today we're going to
incapsulate it and deliver the most
important parts let's start with uh this
this Theory that Satan is the force
behind the music industry and the
question is how did that meeting take
place you know there's a gentleman by
the name of well using the word
gentleman is probably a misplaced word a
very well-known Man by the name of alist
Crowley he's deceased now who became
known as the father of modern occultism
and his determination being raised by a
Christian father when his father passed
away he said he was determined to resist
and to try to obliterate everything
connected to Christianity matter of fact
he even offered himself to a foreign
power to destroy in their country every
facet of Christianity and he wrote a
book it's called a Bible but it's called
The Book of the law lib alious in Latin
meaning the book of the law and the
theme of the book of the law is do what
thou Wilt uh this is a terminology many
years ago when I was a dish jockey in
for the world party
uh there was a group called The eely
Brothers and there was a song called uh
do what you want to do it's your thing
it's your thing do what you want to do
and so many artists insert that kind of
philosophy in their songs um we just
want to have fun and in other words the
a of
irresponsibility it's my life I want to
do whatever I want to do follow your
heart follow your heart uh you set your
goal nobody should prevent you from
accomplishing or pursuing your own
desires and so with the phrase do what
thou Wilt that became a phrase adopted
by the modern hip hop world many
cultures before that matter of fact The
Beatles were known as the early
Disciples of alist Crowley they inserted
his philosophies in many of their songs
if you listen to their songs you would
see the song Imagine Imagine there is no
Heaven no hell below us nothing to live
or die for and then they says imagine
all the people living for it today
correct and then then we hope you join
us and the world will be as one well
Jesus prayed about Oneness but not in
the world Oneness with him and the
father but philosophy of the philosophy
of alist Crowley or the religion called
FMA simply translated meaning will in
the Greek and so this was adopted by the
modern hip hop world and Jay-Z uh there
was a picture taken once of him sporting
a a a jersey a hoodie with the phrase on
the front do what thou Wilt and the
Occult world the hip-hop world The Rock
World the entertainment world have all
used the book of the law written by
aliser Crowley as their Bible and even
JK Rowling you know her with the Harry
Potter series in England uh she has been
known to take many of the excerpts uh
called The Book of Lies also written by
alist Crowley the father of modern
occultism so Satan used someone who
wanted to be uh an agent a disciple for
the Prince of Darkness and he says I
wanted to be Satan's chief of staff and
that is the method by which the
entertainment industry has become very
uh successful implementing satanic
principles through one who made himself
a disciple of Darkness so let's uncover
some of the Masonic and occult uh
religion that they're utilizing in these
uh Industries well you have uh
symbolisms now when you use the word uh
Masonic or ult there's no separation it
just it's just deter it determines how
you approach your goal what do you use
to get to your desired uh level you know
they talk about different levels 33rd
degree where there's really only three
degrees and when you look at Masonic
temples they're built in three levels
three levels but in the dark side of
that when you get to the highest point
uh there's Masonic art where they have
the checkerboard floor well you look a
lot of videos they have the checkerboard
floor the White and the black
symbolizing a presence of good and a
presence of evil wow don't get rid of
either one just combine the two the ying
and the Yang a presence of good and a
presence of evil so when you talk about
occultism Eastern mysticism anything
that's dark they merge good and evil
together and what did Satan say to Eve
in the garden your eyes will be opened
and you shall know good and evil was
never God's intention for for us to know
good and evil so look at those videos
you see the black and the white floor
the black and the white outfits all a a
silent uh confirmation that I'm
connected to the occult world as well as
the Masonic world so in my opinion and
and correct me if I'm wrong but usually
if there's a religion there's a Temple
there's a place where there are worship
you know centers happening so do they
have
these is is an amazing the answer is
going to be amazing a lot of people that
go to concerts mhm are going to the
temples of worship how so well when
Jay-Z had a concert and there's a
picture that I have of Jay-Z reaching
out to his audience he's using the
symbol the
triangle uh there is a false Trinity we
have the true Trinity the Father the Son
and the Holy Spirit Revelation talks
about three unclean spirits coming out
of the mouth of the dragon out of the
mouth of the Beast out of the mouth of
the false prophet that's the false
Trinity I've never connected that and um
so connecting all three sides together
it is a very uh prevalent symbol used in
the occult world and once you recognize
that you'll begin to see it everywhere
as a matter of fact even in our town
here in Thompsonville and West Frankfurt
when you come into the town and you see
the sign welcoming you to town you see a
triangle with a with an eye in the
center which is a symbol of the
allseeing eye in the occult world
so the concert hall though is the place
of worship for the Prince of Darkness uh
that's why there are many people that
have gone to concerts and many many days
later have said I don't remember what
happened that night the stage is really
the Altar and the person on the stage is
the disciple as I stand on the stage to
be a disciple of Christ correct they
stand on the stage to be a disciple of
the Prince of Darkness people that are
converted to Christ become followers
people that are followers of the Prince
of Darkness become what they called fans
which is in fact a fanatic it's a short
word for fanatic they are so in love
with the Prince of Darkness that they
idolize the person who is the visible
representation which is often the movie
stars the the the music producers and
that's why you see many of these
individuals go in and out of disguises
and different costumes keeping their
followers as it were inoculated or
intoxicated or seduced or intrigued
wanting so much to become like them yet
never becoming like them it's Pursuit Of
Darkness so let's go back to the
idolatry that's involved I mean many
people would say that maybe we're
digging too deep we're thinking too far
into it and that it's just music and
that the lyrics are benign let's unplug
that like tell me how is this really an
affirmation of one satanic presence and
how does it indoctrinate people who are
just listening to it some of the most
innocuous songs many years ago uh a man
by the name of Barry Manalo he sang a
song but he didn't write it it was
called I write the songs and I remember
talking about the lyrics in that song
and not until you listen to the lyrics M
matter of fact following the history of
that Barry Mano was very hesitant to
sing the song but the writer of the song
convinced him and it became one of his
top selling songs I mean millions of
songs millions of that song have been
sold um but if you listen to the lyrics
it's clear that that was born in the
heart of the deceiver Lucifer for
himself it says I've been alive forever
and I wrote the very first song I Put
the words and the melody together I am
music and I write the songs second verse
my hold lies deep within you and I have
my own place in your soul and when I
look out through your eyes I am young
again even though I'm very old I write
the songs that make the whole world sing
I write the songs of love and special
things I write the songs that make the
young girls cry I write the songs I
write the songs then it says um music
fills your heart it's a really Fine
Place to Start it's from me to you it's
from you to me it's a worldwide Symphony
and when you look at the lyrics I left
some of that out but it says um you
begin to see wait a minute the guy that
wrote that was has not been alive
forever the guy that wrote that was not
the one who wrote the very first song
and Lucifer one of his gifts he was a
master musician and so Satan's gift now
distorted has been inserted into an
industry that uses the gift of Music
That's why we have to be very careful
even in the Christian world and not to
adopt the styles of music that identify
us with music that's used to seduce
those in the world it's a very fine line
so what I'm hearing you say is that
music is in fact worship it is in fact
worship matter of fact first God us it
for worship you find in Revelation 4
and5 the Angels 247 are praising God you
are worthy to be worshiped to receive
glory and honor and riches and wisdom
and power and glory and blessings
and um this is a Worship the Lord
inhabits the praise of his people that
everything that has breath praise the
Lord uh sing to the Lord a new song and
so you find this is another tool
belonging to God that Satan has used as
an instrument to use to seduce and lead
man to destruction and why not because
he he declared in Isaiah 14:14 I will be
like the most high did and what better
way to be like the most high than to
take what the Most High created and
restored it and twisted not for
salvation but for Destruction and this
is often the Trap that we all find
ourselves in we have gifts and we end up
using them for the enemy and it's not
until we are Justified Sanctified by the
word that we then then realize these
gifts are really meant to glorify one
God the true God that's right and there
are a lot of people that are very
skilled you know a lot of people in the
when somebody says you sing well well
that's a recognition of your talent
correct it's not until that Talent is
given to the Lord that it becomes a
spiritual gift and so when we idolize
those with great talent that's where the
idolization comes in American Idol well
a lot of people are very infatuated with
uh like Beyonce she has a beehive yes um
you know people will tear you apart if
you say anything negative about her um
there's a lot of speculation of whether
or not she's in the occult um have you
found anything evidence that points
toward that being true matter of fact in
her own testimony she does she had a
documentary where she talked about her
Alter Ego Sasha Fierce uh where she says
um this was something that she could not
accomplish Sasha Fierce in in infills
her or endows her with a power that she
does not naturally have and there's a
video in her own words where she talks
about that let's look at that video
sure many years ago I named my Alter Ego
Sasha and it's something that stuck so
when I was trying to to decide the title
of my album I realized it had two
different sounds one represented who I
really am and one sounded like my Alter
Ego so I decided to split it into two
because I I feel like Sasha is a big
treat for my fans um it's definitely
exciting being able to have an excuse to
be so over the
top um and and I think um you definitely
hear the difference I try to keep Sasha
on the stage I absolutely keep Sasha on
the stage and now she has a last name
she's Sasha
Fierce when I perform crazy in love at
the Bett Awards it was almost like my
coming out Sasha is my Alter Ego when
they meet me and they speak with me
they're expecting
Sasha I'm really kind of shy and not
really shy but more reserved and um
nothing like Sasha she can do things
that I cannot do when I'm in rehearsal
I mean I can try but then it just
doesn't happen I can sing notes and sing
Strong and do all these things that when
I'm just by myself I can't do and I
remember right before I performed I
raised my hands up and it was kind of
the first time I I felt something else
come into me and I knew that was going
to be my coming out
night
[Music]
a very clear confession very clear
confession as a matter of fact Katie
Perry also talks about it we don't have
the video on that but Katie Perry talks
about she always wanted to sing like Amy
Grant she was raised in a Christian home
she said I made many attempts I couldn't
do it so at age 15 she says at age 15 I
decided that I'm not going to go the
Christian route and quote so I sold my
soul to the devil
and so when you think of these arter
these are not forced confessions no
simply they're declaring where their
Fame comes from um people might get
perturbed at the idea that I mentioned
this next person's name now I'll just
lay the foundation before I mention the
name can you possibly imagine how you
can
successfully uh get a venue in the city
of sin Las Vegas for 5 years every night
you're going to be performing in the
city of sin for five years Untold wealth
I mean you don't just get that kind of
venue in the city of sin and I speak of
none other than Seline Deon some people
writes nothing but uh love songs and how
is that possible here's the key the
devil doesn't care what Avenue he uses
you know Danny Shelton often says this
and I love this phrase he says he
doesn't care what side of the boat you
fall out of as long as you fall out of
the boat and so in the Garden of Eden
Satan was covert he was more subtle than
any beast of the field but we're living
in in the days of the third temptation
of Christ now what I mean by that is the
first two Temptations in the wilderness
were were cloaked he didn't reveal
himself but in the third Temptation he
revealed himself so we're no longer
living in the age where sin is hidden I
mean it's in your face it's pretty overt
it's in everything it's in everything
food labels Everything music and once
you see it you can't miss it right once
you begin to understand the IDE ideology
and the symbolism and the the things
that are used and the language the
covering of one eye over the other the
um uh the use of the bomet symbol uh
even today you find in the world now
very pushed today the blending of sexes
where a man wants to be a woman a woman
wants to be man and now the world says
you could be any gender you want so we
saw this also within the Hindu religion
the Lord Shiva was half male half female
androgenous and and we see the same in
bafflement exactly so the symbolism is
used in all occult f faets regardless of
culture or location regard and then it's
pushed what's what's amazing today it's
packaged so that people that don't
expect it are drawn in by it uh that's
why I said when I did the series your
eyes will be opened not to know good and
evil but to be able to distinguish
between good and evil and also the
emotions behind it uh there are people
that have been seduced by the music to
do what they never thought they would do
well where do you think that Spirit
comes from that Spirit comes from from a
power that's within it a number of years
ago when I did the series I was
contacted by someone in the
entertainment industry and he revealed
something to me that I had known and I
talked about it in unclean spirits the
second series where when a CD is
produced or a DVD is produced uh wiches
in warlocks they gather around that CD
before it's mastered and they pray that
wherever that DVD or that CD goes an
evil spirit follows it and even some of
the records that have already been
released they'll pull them back and
they'll they'll remaster them yes and I
I just thought this was like a digital
process something they were doing to
clean the sound up but I discovered this
is actually when they do a seance and
they bless it in the name of Satan and
they re-release it to woo more fans and
you wonder sometimes why is my home so
turbulent and you find your child
sequestered in his or her room and they
are being they're being inoculated
they're being literally intravenously
fed you know when the introduction of
earbuds came out or the air where the
there was a time you everybody heard the
music but you could be sitting right
next to your daughter or son and hear
nothing they are being intravenously fed
and music opens an Avenue in your soul
that doesn't have to say should I let
this in it passes the senses it opens
the door and what comes in after that
becomes the point of conditioning so
you'll find children saying certain
things you said where'd you get that
from we don't talk like that in this
family well you could trace it to their
favorite artist you could trace it to
the music that they're listening to so
nowadays when a parent says go to your
room that's exactly where they want to
go go to the room and so then also
there's a symbolism of in the occult
world the Mason world as well as the
occult world has a symbol the third eye
uh there's a picture of um Prince with a
pair sunglasses on he has on a pair
sunglasses with three eyes and then you
the allseeing eye is covered is covered
this this illumination and so
illumination connecting Illuminati it's
this extended branch of control in the
music industry and so could we say that
by listening to their music that we
could see the occult influence or or are
they giving us signs in their
photography and their videos like how
how do we discern if you look at many of
the album covers and I did this in my
second series I keep referring to that
but um you find that the left eye is
always left clear uh for example you
some artists go like this you know liono
Richie uh lady
Gaga yeah Lady Gaga here's a picture of
Lady Gaga covering one eye intentionally
having the other eye you go all the way
back to uh
Adele Kanye West David Bowie David Bowie
Adele Adele list go the list goes on and
on and then you have the the another the
phrase of the Distortion of a title
linked to God Alone he says I am the
resurrection and the life I am the first
and the last well some young people
don't hear the phrase I am until they
first hear it in the music and
entertainment industry for example will
I am correct which black IPS and then
you find if you if you look in those CS
maybe some people have it in their own
homes nowadays It's All Digital on their
devices but if you look at your CDs or
just take a trip to the store and look
at some of those CDs you'll find on more
places than not the phrase I am why do
they use that because Satan wants to
take away the significance of the real I
am mhm and connected to his world a dark
world so what do you recommend here well
the video the the key is being a
disciple of Christ you know the Lord
made a statement in Matthew 24:14 and
this Gospel of the Kingdom shall be
preached in all the world as a witness
unto all nations and then shall the End
come and then Jesus says if anyone
desires to be my disciple let him come
after me deny himself and take up his
cross and F
the devil uses the very same phrase
disciples I have a picture of some of
the disciples that I've I've amassed in
my series uh these are the people that
are very popular artist you go from
Beyonce to Jay-Z to Adele to Kanye West
to I think I said Adele but you can
notice the names that are there Nicki
Minaj well with uh Kanye he seems to
have uh turned the leaf so to speak oh
yeah he matter of fact he has a picture
where he calls himself a yeus mhm and uh
refers to himself as uh uh at least
Jay-Z yahovah correct and there was also
one of the uh very popular magazine
covers where Kanye West was pictured
wearing a crown of
thorns mimicking the crucifixion of
Christ the Divinity of Christ but many
young people that don't read the Bible
that don't have any Christ or
Christianity in their lives their first
introduction to those phrases is in the
entertainment industry in the movie
industry in the music music industry
video games as well video games it's
prevalent everywhere and if your eyes
are not trained to see it then you won't
see it but once you see it and your eyes
are open you cannot miss it and that's
what's missing in the world today so
when you go all the way back to the
modern prophet of occultism alist
Crowley he has a book called The Book of
the law but God has a book and so
depending on which book becomes the
shaping component of your life life will
determine what you see or what you miss
so you're saying by participating in
these things that we become blinded oh
yeah we become blinded because our eyes
have not been opened spiritually you
know Revelation chapter 3 talks about
even the church in the last days he says
um um behold I stand at the door and
knock if anyone hears my voice and open
the door I will come in to him and Su
with him and he with me then he
diagnoses the condition they don't know
that they are wretched miserable poor
for blind and naked and the Apostle Paul
says the God of this world has blinded
their eyes so a lot of people they don't
want to hear religious things or even
consider the things of Christianity
because their eyes are opened in a
different direction and so Satan's job
is to keep you distracted and why have
they left because in the Bible you find
when we are blessed he says Jesus went
and sat down at the right hand of the
Father the right hand is the place of
divinity when you overcome come you'll
sit down with me on my Throne at on the
right hand the Sheep are called the
right hand the goats are on the left and
the goat is a symbol also used in the
occult World a Lady Gaga once had on an
outfit where she had the goat horns
which is a part of the whole baffet
symbol the goat horns so while we think
people are saying hey how you doing No
in fact they're flashing the symbol of
their allegiance in the power that has
given them the fame and fortune that
they have so the secrets that Alistar
Crowley or Crowley MH uh garnered he's
then given them over to these
disciples what are they doing with it I
mean what's the end goal you know when
we talk about disciples and how it
correlates and compares to Disciples of
Christ I want to start with Revelation
16 because this is very significant to
understand the power behind it you know
the Lord calls us to be his disciples
and we Champion a cause for
righteousness Satan calls his followers
to be disciples
and they Champion a cause for Darkness
for Destruction and in both Powers we're
not wrestling against 15 different
powers we are wrestling between light
and darkness good and evil and so as I
read Revelation 16:13 it gives us
insight into what's really taking place
behind the scenes Revelation 16:13 and I
saw three unclean spirits like I
referred to earlier the false Trinity
out of the mouth of the dragon out of
the mouth of the Beast out of the mouth
of the false prophet what the power
behind them verse 14 for they are the
spirits of demons performing signs which
go out to the kings of the earth and of
the whole world to gather them to the
Battle of that great day of God Almighty
so this final battle is not going to be
against China or Russia in some Valley
somewhere in the Middle East it is a
battle between light and darkness good
and evil truth and error and the initial
claim I talked about a moment ago Satan
said I will be like the most high but he
knows he has a short time Revelation
12:12 woe to the inhabitants of the
earth and of the sea for the devil has
come down unto you having great wrath
because he knows he has a short time so
he has taken this kamakazi Spirit there
was a time that much of we talked much
of what we talked about was hidden but
it's in plain sight it's no
longer uh overt it's now right it's no
long covert it's now overt it's right
before us we see it all and the way men
are being treated the way women are
being treated the the confusion the
dysphoria the the gender
uh what's that phrase gender dysphoria
people not knowing or not even
identifying or very well intelligent
people not admitting what God created
but giving uh descent and I say descent
because they're lowering the standard
acknowledging something that there's a
power behind them that is not godly so
our world is not here by coincidence
Jeremiah says we sowed the wind now
we're reaping the world wind you can't
sow Darkness
and expect light you can't SE error and
expect truth so we're coming to a close
here but we're going to have you back on
the next program tell me in a few words
what is it that we should be looking
forward to we have to look for light you
can't find light in darkness God's word
is a lamp into our feet and a light unto
our path when you open God's word you
don't open the book of the law written
by man aliser Crowley you open written
by and inspired by the Holy Spirit the
Bible and then those who have never read
the Bible their eyes will be opened they
will see good and evil but they'll see
evil to avoid it and good to follow it
and so I recommend those of you that are
watching the program if you think about
what God wants to do in your life
consider God's word as the alternative
even if you have a lot of music many
people have discarded all the music they
had and given their lives to God's word
a good time to begin is today great
thank you so much for being with us
today up to the present biblical
prophecy remains 100% % accurate there
is no reason to suppose that what is
written of the end times within the
books of Daniel and Revelation is the
exception we urge you to start thinking
critically about how you are being
influenced and to what end Proverbs 2012
States ears to hear and eyes to see both
are gifts from the
[Music]
Lord